a bad decision-making route what's
what's funny about this is that he so we
caught him like on his way into federal
prison originally so in November of 2013
Alex was in the midst of the arbitration
that you see at the end you know we that
we portray at the end of the movie in mm
MLB's offices in Manhattan and we got a
call from his publicist and his
publicist says yo alex is on a break
from the arbitration and he's coming
down to Miami he's got an office in
Coral Gables which is just like very
wealthy affluent suburb adjacent to the
city of Miami and it's actually the city
where the University of Miami is located
where Alex Rodriguez field is at um on
campus and so they said listen Alex
would like to meet with you to talk
about possibly doing some kind of
tell-all documentary Jesus is November
2013 so I'm like yes please
yeah so I figured like this is a
hush-hush meeting you know we're and do
this on the down-low at his office and
Coral Gables they say meet us some
weekday high noon at Hill Stone
restaurant which is the power lunch spot
in that neighborhood the most prominent
corner in the city floor-to-ceiling
windows open kitchen everybody from the
street to the dishwasher can see
everything going on in that dining room
they want to meet us there at noon so
I'm like oh okay
we go there slammed every seat taken mob
scene around the host and three four
deep at the bar they escort us down the
center me and my producer Alfred
Spellman right down the center aisle
parade us practically and you know ESPN
in the 34 30s they really fetishized the
directors so like they have like video
interviews with us like you know in
bumpers like every hour like little
little segments and so people sometimes
recognize me usually in Miami like close
to um because we did the um you know
dock so if there was any play any place
how it was gonna be recognized it was
two miles from the University of Miami
and so take us right down the middle and
there in the center booth on this
elevated platform around the back is
Alex Rodriguez holding court
and we literally have to like step up on
stage to join him and like all eyes are
on us in this place and I don't know
what we kind of get introduced and I
need like an icebreaker so I'm like so
who's gonna call page six you were us
sure as shit two weeks later was in page
six and so we sit there and um Alex
didn't laugh the publicist laughs that's
like a publicist joke you know yes so
because it was clear that we were there
to be seen having this meeting yeah it
was so clear why do you think they did
that it was it was part of Alex's when
you said was there a plan there was kind
of a plan it was part of Alex's like PR
offensive or push back against major
league baseball and so we sat there with
him for almost an hour and a half and he
just lied just lied to us
um the whole time and I didn't know that
I'm not a about everything I never met
Tony posh this is all people you look at
my records I you know I my performance
didn't improve after the time he claims
to have been treating me I'm not a
baseball fan I'm like you to me they I
call it screensaver all right I I just
but my producing partner Alfred is a
degenerate baseball thing he gets to
look to fucking mlb.com package has it
on his desk on his iPad all day long
during the season I'm just like I I mean
I guess he does that instead of ambien
you know thing less sleep eating with
baseball I guess I don't know so he's
just like but he's a huge baseball fan
and when I left I was like he made a lot
of good points Alex did office like
fucking lied about everything and I
can't blame him he lied to everybody in
those days I mean he was in a he was
desperately trying to salvage as his
career and his legacy and he allegedly
lied to the DEA in a queen for a day
meeting who the fuck lies in a queen for
a day meeting other than George
papadopolis I mean your support the
whole point is you're supposed to tell
the truth that they're not gonna kind of
fuck with you um but but he allegedly
did that so does the Queen for the
amazing so queen for a day meeting with
the feds you get a letter for it they're
like we're investigating we you're a
witness and investigation we understand
you may have participated in some
illegality or committed some crimes in
the course of this larger investigation
but we're not after you we just want you
to come in
feel comfortable and free to tell the
truth to our investigators so that we
can pursue our investigation accurately
and fairly and we will not whatever
anything you say will not be held
against you essentially in a court of
law
so you're queen for a day they call it
you get a letter or queen for a day
letter and they'll actually call it that
they call it queen for a day and so I
don't that's the thing the feds have and
so Alex was free to just speak the only
thing you can't do is lie to a federal
agent mmm that is a crime and that is in
fact I think what George papadopolis was
ultimately he lied in his queen for a
day meeting the whole point of a queen
for a day meeting is to test not run lie
and not in because you can't get in
trouble essentially for any crimes
that you admit there about the
investigation so that was the
allegations that he actually lied so I
listen I'm a documentarian people lie to
me for a living I'm I'm fine with that
especially because they spelled my name
right in page six and that shit was
involved I don't have the juice to make
that happen
Alex's Alex his publicist had the juice
to make to make that happen I was
flattered that they'd you know write
about me but like but you didn't think
that he was lying I suspected he wasn't
telling us the whole truth but I thought
he made some interesting points in
Alfred so Alfred had was a picture in
high school North Miami Beach Senior
High go chargers and Alfred had actually
pitched against Alex Rodriguez it's like
one of his only war stories from his
baseball years in high school right is
that Alex was a senior I think Alfred
was going to some sort of Ron Frazier
baseball camp at a um and they did the
summer league game and Alfred this is my
eyes are glazing over telling this story
but like Alfred
Alfred's pitches against a ride who was
already a senior already a beast
everybody knew this guy was gonna was
gonna go in the draft and be huge
everybody knew about that that he had
been the talk of the high school
baseball community in Miami forever and
so Alfred pitched against him and he
held a rod to a triple of course Alec
you know a rod smacked the shit out of
this ball sailed away but he he was it
was only a triple wasn't it was a rare
not homerun for Alex so I thought oh we
have like a funny personal anecdote like
we can find some common ground here
right you're talking to someone who
might be a potential
interview subject you know and so I'm
like actually Alex you and Alfred have
met before
alpha rolls his eyes like he's gonna
embarrass me and tell this dumb shit
story so I tell out like isn't this
funny like you guys but and Alfred held
you to a triple and he kind of looked at
me like you're looking at me right now
he's just he was totally unamused and
maybe looked even a little hurt or
offended this is the greatest baseball
one of the greatest baseball players of
all time the highest paid baseball
player in history and here I'm just
telling this cute story from like 20
years earlier or whatever and he seemed
like he held me to a triple I'm like how
could you be upset about that you're one
of the greatest of all time like super
winners but it's like yeah it's that's
why I left I was like this guy's a
really interesting character like he's a
complicated guy he's an interesting
guy's a sensitive guy like I was curious
about him I was excited about the
prospect of interviewing him and man
they finally ghosted us out yeah the
January of 2014 that's when they lowered
they reduced his suspension I started
hitting up every month started hitting
up the publicist yo following up on that
meeting you know because it's funny in
the page six article it mentioned he met
with the 34:30 filmmakers Billy Corbin
Alfred Spellman he's been shopping a
book proposal to these publishers the
book proposal thing was total bunk
literally not true the the the
publishers are like we'd love to get one
but we haven't gotten a book proposal
from a-rod he really did have the
meeting with us but like everything was
just we were just kind of pawns in his
game which is cool whatever
I'll respond to this documentary not
exactly but I for only six or seven
months I'm emailing with the publicist
and then it was clear that they weren't
interested so and that became the tactic
by the way when you said was there a
strategy the strategy was to shut the
fuck up
hmm and just like like you said like
with the president big New York Times
big escandalo a scandal or expose and
then maybe if we just tomorrow in this
24-hour news cycle in this fucking in
this world of just being us being
hammered with bad news you know in 240
characters every nanosecond of every day
just shit just passes and they just they
they played it just so so beautifully
and brilliantly